take a look at those two numbers
the first one is the average salary of a
cyber security professional in the U.S
nice numbers the second one is the
number of positions that are open in the
U.S 750
000. and the good news is it's
increasing
the number one question I get on my
LinkedIn after people see these videos
is how can I get a career in cyber
security so I'm recording this video to
give you an idea some of the answer to
that so what I want to provide you with
are some of the things that will get you
to that that point so it involves
training it involves credentials it
involves a career path and then
ultimately stay to the end and I'm going
to show you some resources about how you
can go collect your version of this as
well so first of all let's start off
with training so
what do you need to know in terms of
being a cyber security professional well
the the training aspect one of the
options that's been the traditional one
this is the one that I went through but
not everyone has to do this as you're
going to see Bachelor of Science in
something like computer science or I.T
some of those related fields and then
maybe you add on to that an additional
cyber security concentration
so I teach at a local University and I
teach people on that cyber security
concentration
another path is an associate's degree
so here you're talking about probably a
two-year degree or some sort of
vocational training
and this is going to be something that's
going to cost less
and and still could be a valid entry
point for some folks it's going to be
taking a boot camp
so this is a very specific
intensive short duration security
training and then finally an option you
can consider and some of these are
available online and they're free is a
certificate of some sort in fact IBM
offers one of these from an organization
called Coursera so if you think about
this this is going to be your most
expensive of the options
a little bit less a little bit less all
the way down to in some of these cases
it's zero now of course what you're
spending is going to have something to
do with the kinds of jobs and doors that
get open for you so I'm not going to say
all of these lead to the same place but
they're all different entry points into
the cyber security career space so they
all should be considered now the next
thing I'm going to talk about is
credentials so what kind of things do
you need to do
to get the job you've got the training
now you have to prove that you're
qualified for the job and the most
common of these are professional
certifications the one that's considered
the gold standard in the security space
is a thing called a cissp
certified information system security
professional that's the one that most of
the jobs are looking for it's not an
entry level cert though in order to get
this it requires five years of
experience in the field it requires that
you pass an exam that's about 100 to 150
questions multiple choice by the way
back in the day when I took the exam it
was 250 questions so thankfully for
those of you coming along it's gotten
easier there's an Ethics statement that
you have to sign off on there is also an
endorsement so you need an existing
cissp to endorse you and then there's
ongoing cpes in other words education
credits that you need to be able to get
this is again the ones that's in most
demand but it's not for entry level
folks to be able to get all of these
things the next one though that is a
more entry-level cert
is Security Plus
Security Plus has a lower bar to meet
it's two years of experience there's an
exam there's 90 questions on the exam so
that just gives you kind of a little bit
of an idea so it's not for someone
that's brand new but it's not the same
high bar a lot more people have Security
Plus than have cissp and jobs are
offering positions for people that have
that level some other certs that you
might consider the cisa for Auditors the
cism
for managers there's a number of
different certificates and credentials
that could be useful but those are some
of the ones that you might want to
consider now how about a career path
once you've got the training you've got
the certs you've got the credentials
what are you going to do in terms of
your career where does all of this lead
well there's a great website called
cyberseek.org and it has some nice
animations you're going to see an
example right here where you can start
off with a feeder role so an example if
you start with networking experience and
then from there you can lead to an
entry-level cyber security position and
then from there you can see what sort of
mid-level cyber security positions that
might lead to and then ultimately what
sort of advanced positions all of this
could lead to so that's a great resource
for you to go and explore and look and
see what kinds of things you're
interested in and where all of this can
lead
finally I told you I would give you some
resources
what kinds of things are out there to
help you once you want to try to do
something like this well I already
mentioned one and that's cyberseak.org
which again allows you to explore these
career paths and certification paths and
things of that sort another really good
one is from Coursera and IBM IBM worked
with Coursera to develop a certificate
for
an example like this an online cert
doesn't cost you anything to do and it
will introduce you to the field of cyber
security as an analyst and then finally
uh a place like ibm.com jobs if you are
interested in a cyber security job at
IBM and again I get these questions all
the time on LinkedIn and this is my
answer to folks go look there that's
where we post all of our openings and of
course there are a lot of others out
there as well so the good news is
there's lots of money to be made there
are a lot of positions to be filled if
you want some of this this is how you
get it
thanks for watching if you found this
video interesting and would like to
learn more about cyber security please
remember to hit like And subscribe to
this channel